we need to go back to where every
situation in life is not a 24-hour cable
news show we're a conversation with my
aunt is not a 24-hour cable news show or
I have to have statistics and talking
points every time she picks up the phone
and I'm like well actually in Texas the
hospitalization it's declined but the
death is we can't do it we can't go on
like this forever we have to go back to
something that's more like normalcy we
have we can't do it people are exhausted
everybody you know now is a pundit
politics is for losers haven't we
explained that is it could that not be
more clear to you every now and that in
politics somebody gets in was like a
good looking winner and then they become
the president and then they try to
change engine then they get shot in the
head while her him and his wife drive
through Dallas but for the most part the
people that write about politics the
people that obsess about politics all
they are losers they cannot get laid
they have no friends they don't make any
money they have zero capital anywhere in
their life financial social and they
spend their time figuring out why why am
i a loser and then that leads them down
whatever rabbit hole whichever wherever
they're gonna go and they're just losers
nobody wants to be these people you
don't so we need we need to get away
from the idea that like people should be
consumed all day with about with their
political identity there's more to life
there is more to life than politics
truly not saying you shouldn't fight for
things you believe them but you're also
not fighting for anything you believe in
you're pretending so there's more to
life go out take a bunch of shrooms sit
on a hill have a good grilled cheese
sandwich pay someone to jerk you off at
a bus stop I don't know it's not my
business but there's got to be more to
life than debating obscure German
philosophers and we know what you're
doing there
or [ __ ] you know talking about
critical race theory I'm sick of the
free speech tube am sick of that I'm
sick of the canceled culture horseshit
on both sides I'm sick of idiots like
Acacio Cortez being like real council
culture effects anti-imperialists and
Palestinian advocates and I'm like [ __ ]
you don't think Google and [ __ ]
Facebook are gonna sense them you don't
think they're gonna censor Palestinian
advocate what do you what is wrong with
you [ __ ] weren't you [ __ ] saying
you're Jewish the other day she'd pull
up that clip where al see I don't know
if he can't even find it she's talking
to some group but she says she's a
little Jewish since I cut it out AOC
yeah welcome to the tribe a o'seas
Jewish background like can we stop yeah
she's she went and she was talking to I
think a Jewish group and and she says um
you know play this clip here it's fraud
[Music]
like you see he senses that these people
are frauds what is wrong with you
they're actors they are frauds she's
claiming to be a bagel and then she's
going to hang out with Ilan Omar and
never heed mine cop they don't believe
in anything
they're frauds you people put your
stocking she's hot if she looked like me
she'd be another loser socialist in a
basement right now talking about capital
but she looks like her so she's on
television every 36 seconds let's not
get it twisted she's full of [ __ ] she's
in front of a Jewish audience and all
the sudden it's Jews and then the next
time she talks it's like it's about the
power staring at it date it stop it
you're gonna let these people run your
life you're on earth for a certain
amount of time and you're investing in
that you're investing this these are the
types of people you're investing in or
Trump was they dancing with Epstein like
this for 30 years and the decides saying
he doesn't know who he is
these are the people that you're gonna
spend your time investing in what what
kind of perpetual state of [ __ ]
childhood Peter Pan syndrome is this
where you spend your entire [ __ ] life
listening to these goons all the [ __ ]
they want to do is get power and you
give it to them so easily